the following episode contains spoilers
for the first two episodes of loki
me i presume please if anyone is
anyone then i am you i have an offer
that's why i found you
let's hear it i'm gonna overthrow the
algorithm and cards on the table i could
use a good lieutenant yin
i don't know look just show yourself
this cold open ain't getting any colder
fine but be warned the truth isn't
always what you expect
yeah so that's the big twist huh
yep hmm okay uh should we just hop into
the theory then
sorry sorry it was the slip of the
tongue i i think that would be for the
best
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
where i encourage you to hit that
subscribe button and ring the bell so we
can magically appear in your sacred
timeline
of youtube videos speaking of blowing up
timelines holy cow does marvel studios
know how to use their chaos magic to
turn wednesdays on social media
into one big nexus event the first
episode of the new disney plus series
loki set
record numbers and considering the
reveals that happened last night the
social posts aren't slowing down anytime
soon i mean just as it looked like
episode 2 was settling into a comfy
episodic groove
kablooey another huge bombshell as it's
revealed that the variant loki
r loki is chasing on behalf of the tva
is a woman
[Music]
female loki oh and she also set off a
bomb that maybe blew up reality as we
know it and may have just recreated the
multiverse and here you thought the
gender reveals that started forest fires
were bad
anyway we've still got four episodes
left to go in this thing who or what
else could we be seeing next
kid loki lucky charms loki colonel
sanders loki okay i made that last one
up but admit it you wouldn't be
surprised i see you colonel sanders
i see you white clad finger looking good
loki's aside this is a show where
literally
anything is possible i mean the central
conceit is all about time travel
alternate timelines weapons that rewind
and fast forward individual people
grenades that can blow up entire
realities multiple characters that can
cast illusions
duplicate themselves and use mind
control even a cosmic bureaucracy
seemingly so powerful that they can
vaporize demigods and use infinity
stones as paperweights we actually get a
lot of those
i mean not only is everything on the
table but like
everything is on the table that's why
it's good i'm not here today to try and
predict what's gonna happen in the show
instead i'm here to predict what the
show is about yes those are two
very separate very distinct things
though admittedly i might also throw in
some what's gonna happen stuff in here
too
no what i'm really interested in today
is the meta text
the stuff that's happening around the
margins of this story because two
episodes end i'm getting a strong sense
of where this is
all headed and what the goal of this
show really is and if i'm right well
then i think i know who the real bad guy
of loki is
it's you so let's unpack this behold
my stuff what we're doing today is a
type of literary criticism called new
historicism
literary criticism is basically a fancy
word for interpreting a work of art and
supporting your analysis with evidence
basically a slightly more sophisticated
version of writing a five paragraph
essay for your english class
and there are lots of different ways to
do it you can look at the historical
context around a work you can look at
the author and their beliefs you can ask
whether the author is a socialist or a
feminist or has an unconscious oral
fixation that's coming out through their
work or
you could just ignore all of that stuff
and just read the darn book or watch the
darn movie and analyze that don't worry
we're not going anywhere near that deep
new historicism criticism looks at the
work in its historical context under the
belief that hey
this book or movie isn't just a product
of an author but the product of a moment
in history
if you really want to understand what
its intention is you have to also
understand the historical context into
which it was published and so that is
what we're about to do with loki to
understand why beneath everything else
this is a show
about us and our relationship with the
current state of marvel so let's start
at the very top and work our way down
shall we start with what we explicitly
see
take place on screen loki the series
follows shock of all shocks loki
not the same one that we know from the
first 14 years of mcu movies he's still
dead most likely instead this loki is
the one from endgame who grabbed the
tesseract and escaped into a portal when
the avengers kind of bungled their time
heist
thus creating an alternate timeline
except what no one expected was that the
new timelines don't get to split off for
very long
apparently there's a way overpowered
cosmic police agency called the time
variance authority that monitor things
like when a stray loki goes rogue
and immediately swoop in to collect them
drag them off to tva
hq for processing and set off suspicious
looking grenades that appeared to delete
incorrect timelines from existing
and yup if you'd been waiting however
long for one of these things to answer
whether or not a marvel cinematic
multiverse exists loki has your answer
no the tva makes sure that it can't but
a multiverse used to exist
see apparently there did used to be a
whole mess of different universes but
that was a bad thing because all the
different realities kept fighting with
each other
long ago there was a vast multiversal
war
which you know is gonna be the premise
of a movie one day
you know it's coming and you also know
that you want it i mean like i
and everyone else watching this scene on
premiere night immediately demanded it
from our mouse-eared overlords
anyway moving on supposedly the
multiverse problem was solved by a trio
of omnipotent cosmic beings called the
time keepers blasting the whole shebang
into a single reality called the sacred
timeline a single beginning to end
straight line telling one true version
of the story and the tva's role is to
make sure that the past present and
future
all still happen the way they're
supposed to by preventing variants like
the escaped loki
from creating nexus events which spin
off into alternate timelines
now why does that word sound so familiar
nexus
because the world doesn't revolve around
you but instead of erasing our variant
loki from existence entirely tva
agent mobius wants to put him to work
catching a rogue loki that's causing all
sorts of problems so that's what's
happening on the surface but now let's
go one layer deeper into the themes of
the show
the themes based on this initial premise
are pretty darn clear
identity freedom versus determinism and
the possibility of redemption i mean the
whole plot is
loki literally on a quest to find loki
doesn't get any more explicit than that
and then not only is he tasked with
finding himself but he also has to learn
who he himself is in a sea of
himself and in a world where his
decisions are predetermined as the first
episode says you ridiculous bureaucrats
will not dictate how my story ends
it's not your story mr lauferson it
never was
and again with lady loki this isn't
about you
and that my friends is our big question
in a world where everything is
predetermined by a sacred timeline what
does it mean be free
go figure the god of mischief is on the
side of upsetting the apple cart and not
being told what to do whereas the tva
believes that the sacred timeline has to
be upheld no matter what which leads to
probably the easiest prediction theory
that i've ever had to make on the
channel
the time variance authority are not the
good guys in the story
what no that is shocking go figure the
regime of time space
middle managers are bad despite them
saying that they're good who would have
thunk it
it's not like there were any signs along
the way like say their minutemen field
agents dressed like heavily armored riot
cops they're processing centers
deliberately evoking the beige
fluorescent lit dehumanizing mazes of a
dmv or a small claims court and their
entire overall aesthetic evoking a mix
of mid-century american meets early
soviet bureaucracy
not too hard to read this writing on the
wall but what's even more
concerning is their philosophy
especially in the mcu where
individuality
free will and the idea that we are not
bound to our fate are like the core
moral components to almost every major
hero just look at gamora
nebula bucky barnes heck even the
original loki changed his ways to fight
against hela and thanos
but that's not how the tva sees it
instead mobius informs loki that his
evil nature was
always the plan in the sacred timeline
right up until it wasn't that his only
real purpose was to be a bad guy
for the good guys to become good guys by
defeating him you weren't born to be
king loki you were born to cause pain
and suffering and death that's how it is
that's how it was
that's how it will be all so that others
can achieve their best versions of
themselves
but here's the kicker they don't really
have an explanation for
why things have to be how they are we're
told the multiverse was bad to begin
with but well we we don't actually know
if that's true
we're supposed to take them at their
word even though the time keepers stay
out of sight and apparently only
directly communicate with judges the
timeline is sacred
because the time keepers say it is
period just take it on faith the whole
thing
sounds an awful lot like a religion with
omnipotent god-like beings communicating
their will through a chosen few that you
just gotta believe heck in episode 2
when loki finally asks what the end of
the whole big story is
mobius says that they don't know they're
waiting for the time keepers to untangle
it and fill them in
how does it all end that's a work in
progress
oh there's lazy timekeepers what are
they waiting for oh contraire
no because while we protect what came
before
they are toiling away in their chamber
untangling
the epilogue from its infinite branches
i see so when they're finished what
happens then
so are we in other words the tva doesn't
even know what they're fighting
dying and running cosmic black ops for
forget religion
that's called a cult and if they're
truly the bad guys well
remember that judge that sentences loki
her name is
ravona renslayer in the comics this name
belongs to a princess
consort and on-again-off-again romantic
interest to kang the conqueror one of
the most feared and powerful marvel
villains ever
and wouldn't you know it he just so
happens to be a villain from the future
obsessed with reordering the timeline to
ensure his victories
using time travel reality hopping and
illusions to get
exactly what he wants sounds an awful
lot like the time keepers supervising
the tva doesn't it and i learned from my
mistakes watching wanda vision if it
looks like an agatha harkness and wears
a brooch like an agatha harkness then
chances are it's an agatha harkness so
big bad time travel guy with a close
hench person named ravona in every
episode lingering on that final face in
the center of the courtroom just saying
there's a chance that all these stories
are connected it also helps that the
actor jonathan magers is believed to be
playing kang the conqueror in the
upcoming ant-man and the wasp movie
so we know that there's a high
likelihood that this guy's gonna show up
in the relatively near future but now
it's time to get into layer 3 of our
analysis why
we're the villains of this whole thing
the meta narrative
think about what role the time keepers
play in the meta-narrative of loki's
story so far
omnipotent beings who are aware of
everything that's ever happened
or will ever happen and you have the
ability to send ultra powerful agents to
any place in the universe at any point
in time
but instead of rescuing people from
danger or stopping disasters or even
trying to make anything better
they're exclusively concerned with
making sure that the events on a
timeline that they decided was the right
version
the sacred version no less continues to
happen in the way that they already
know them to have happened despite all
their titles these guys aren't keeping
time they're keeping
continuity those stuffy bureaucrats and
jack-booted thugs with batons going
around literally beating up variants and
blowing up mistakes that's meant to be
us that marvel meta-narrative is
pointing back at fans who might be
getting ready to ruin everyone's fun
because the timeline isn't perfect the
dark hold from agents of shield doesn't
look exactly like the dark hold from
wandavision and in case you think
that seems to be a little on the nose
for the moral of the series remember
captain marvel
ended with every guy who complained
about the concept of carol danvers being
overpowered gets ragdolled across the
desert
prove to me you can beat me
meanwhile it's pretty clear based on how
the series is turning out in the
upcoming slate of films that loki is
either going to end with fracturing the
sacred timeline or
is setting the table for that to happen
early on in doctor strange multiverse of
madness the worst kept secret in
hollywood is that marvel's next big
trick is probably that a cinematic
universe is about to become a cinematic
multiverse the sony marvel partnership
is doing another animated spider-verse
movie pretty much everyone already knows
that spider-man no way home is
some kind of multiverse movie as well
there's references to both the mcu
and the sam raimi spider-man movies in
the trailers of both venom 2 and morbius
and they're about to launch an animated
anthology series entirely about
alternate reality storylines whatever
they ultimately decide a multiverse
means in this context the marvel
multiverse is coming
probably pretty soon it's a good way to
manage the expanding roster of
properties it lets you revisit
characters you've otherwise retired you
can try out ideas that might not be
ready for the mainstream as well as keep
characters who might not play well with
everyone else like deadpool blade and
punisher
safely in their own spaces you could use
it as a hand wave to pull in established
characters you've acquired from
elsewhere but keep them in their more
famous forms all while fixing
inconsistencies but the thing about a
multiverse is
just like miss minutes says in episode 1
they're messy they're chaotic things get
jumbled up
so do you kowtow to the time keepers and
limit yourself to a strict deterministic
series of events like the tva
blindly following a path towards some
unknown ends or
do you side with loki and loosen up a
bit and allow for a little bit of chaos
cause guess what
chaos can be kind of fun well if i'm
right about this and i'm feeling good
about it so far then the loki series is
marvel telling us their decision
a little bit of mess is worth it in the
long run because it lets them do more
fun stuff when it comes down to a choice
between
avoiding a continuity error or doing
something awesome
they are going to try to do something
awesome does time travel mean that
suddenly steve rogers stayed oddly
silent throughout national tragedies
like the vietnam war
how did dr strange get everyone
organized for the big final portal
charge shouldn't he have intervened at
some point throughout the entirety of
wandavision mistakes like that are gonna
happen but isn't it worth it just to
hear falcon's voice over cap's earpiece
on your left so whatever else loki
ends up having to reveal about the
future past or in between of the mcu
the real statement lady loki was making
when she bombed the sacred timeline was
all about the series's meta narrative
not just putting the time keepers on
notice for whatever their canonical
agenda is but telling
us to brace ourselves for the messy the
chaotic but the much more interesting
and narratively fulfilling multiverse to
come
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cut almost because i'm gonna
be derailing the timeline of this
episode on behalf of our sponsor
displate this plate loves fans and
fandoms they were good enough to hop
aboard this episode to support us and i
would love it if you showed them some
support in return by clicking the link
in the description below
i know a large portion of you watching
are proud members of various fandoms
throughout the internet whether it's
star wars the mcu classic video games or
heck just cats a lot of you are artists
yourselves or appreciate art that helps
express your fandom and this plate is
like the perfect
match for everyone who watches these
episodes that is not
an exaggeration disc plate is an art
company they have beautiful prints but
they're not
flimsy paper prints or even canvas these
things are metal plate prints yes
metal a material that can actually
survive the entirety of your life
whether you're in a dorm room your first
apartment or like your sixth house the
prints are gorgeous incredibly high
quality with vivid colors
and best of all they can be mounted on
the wall using special stickers and
magnetic plates that come with
the artwork that means no damage to your
walls no having to use
drywall screws no having to awkwardly
hang and rebalance things you literally
do not need to own or have
ever lifted a hammer i got a ton of
prints from them they are literally all
over my house right now and i hung them
all
in less than three minutes i got
inspired by my love of classic nintendo
games and minecraft i also got some cats
because i was just really into the
design of these cats i mean look at how
incredible these guys are they have a
zillion prints and among them wouldn't
you know it are beautiful designs
inspired by the man himself
loki there are a huge number of posters
available to capture one of the coolest
characters in the mcu during displayed
special partnership for the show
i'm really loving the retro vibe of some
of these but there's also a huge range
of styles and colors to go with your
space and your vibe
check them out poke around on the site
it's just fun to look at all the
different artwork that's available and i
guarantee that you will find something
that you fall in love with on top of
that displate is a give back company who
donates a portion of their proceeds to
reforestation programs around the world
on an ongoing basis
not just when it's cool to do so or when
they're getting publicity for it so you
get something amazing you help them make
the world a little bit better in the
process you don't need any more
convincing you just need to get
in there and become the art collector
that you were born to be
that link is down in the description
below i encourage you to check them out
because they supported this channel and
they deliver an amazing service and i'll
see you all
next week
you